continuing his attack on Nikki Haley I
now want to uh highlight for you a truly
hilarious and also completely
unbelievable and kind of self-owning
statement that Donald Trump made about
Nikki Haley let me back it up Nikki
Haley worked for Donald Trump's
Administration and what I mean by that
is Donald Trump made Nikki Haley
ambassador to the United Nations for the
United States and Trump has a long
history of saying I hire the best people
that I that's one of the things I do I
hire the absolute best people it was a
joke Trump hired some of the worst
people and regularly had to fire them
and claim that they were actually bad
people and he was somehow duped or they
were good but then became bad or you
know he's had to explain how did you
hire all these bad people fine so one of
the issues here is how is Trump going to
attack Nikki Haley given that Trump was
positive and enough about Nikki Haley to
hire her and make her part of his
administration well Trump's new line
which he is talking about of course on
his platform truth social
is he hired her to be an ambassador
to help the people of South Carolina by
getting her out of South Carolina this
is I mean it's it's truly amazing stuff
Trump posting to truth social quote the
greatest thing Nikki Haley did for our
country and the great state of South
Carolina was accepting the position of
United Nations Ambassador so that the
incredible then Lieutenant Governor
Henry McMaster could be the governor of
South Carolina where he has done an
absolutely fantastic job that was a big
reason why I appointed Nikki to the
position it was a favor to the people I
love in South Carolina this is of course
absurd gaslighting think about what
Trump wants you to believe he thought of
trump was sitting there when he became
president
thinking to himself okay let's see Nikki
Haley's a terrible governor I want to
help the people of South Carolina so the
way I'm going to help the people of
South Carolina is I'm going to make
Nikki Haley Ambassador even though she's
a terrible elected official
just to get her out of South Carolina
in order
to help that state by making Henry
McMaster the governor this is idiocy
nobody would believe that this is what
Donald Trump did but the real story here
is it's only February of the year before
the election it's not February 2024 and
it's getting this insane it's February
2023 and it's already completely Bonkers
and insane this is going to get way
crazier and just wait until more people
get into this race